biryani is a perfectly cooked rice dish
seasoned with whole spices and layered
between tender chunks of meat and
streams of delicious gravy it's a dish
that will give you the perfect bite each
time
today we're gonna make our favorite
biryani recipe that is sure to keep
everyone you know coming back for more
the origin of biryani is debatable some
say it originated in iran making its way
across india through trade routes others
say it originated in tamil nadu one
thing everyone can agree on however is
that biryani is delicious almost every
region of south asia has their own style
of biryani hyderabad's version is extra
saucy and flavorful in tamil ambur
biryani is made with mint yogurt
marinade and in lucknow they sometimes
use stock to create a richer flavor
today we're going to be making bombay
style biryani it's a little sweet and
topped with crispy fried onions let's
start with the meat there are many
protein options when it comes to making
biryani like goat lamb shrimp and
chicken for our recipe we're going with
chicken since it's the most traditional
we're using bone-in chicken thighs and
drumsticks boneless chicken works too
but bone-in will help to give us a more
flavorful dish to incorporate even more
flavor in our chicken we're going to
marinate it we tested both a spice based
marinade and a yogurt-based marinade we
found that marinating with yogurt is key
to getting creamy tender chicken so
that's what we're going with full fat
yogurt works best in a large bowl
combine the yogurt ginger paste garlic
paste salt cumin coriander garam masala
chili powder and lime juice we'll add
the chicken and toss to coat well
then cover the bowl with plastic wrap
and marinate for one hour at room
temperature or up to three hours in the
refrigerator
now let's prepare our rice
for this recipe we will be using basmati
it's fragrant slightly nutty and will
pair really nicely with our mix of
spices we'll start by gently rinsing the
rice in cool water
repeat this a few times until the water
runs clear
now we'll cover the rice with fresh
water and let it soak for 30 to 45
minutes
not only does soaking the rice help to
remove excess starch and speed up the
cooking process but for fragrant rice
like basmati and jasmine this will also
help strengthen their natural aroma and
flavors
once the rice has finished soaking we'll
move on to the cooking process to a pot
of water add cardamom pods a cinnamon
stick
bay leaf cloves and salt
when that comes to a boil we'll add our
rice the key to perfectly cooked biryani
is to cook the rice until it's only
about three quarters of the way done so
it's still al dente this should only
take about four minutes
drain
then add the rice to a plate or baking
sheet and spread in an even layer to
cool like this
now that our rice is done we can move on
to our next three ingredients that will
make our biryani extra special
onions prunes and potatoes we'll first
boil the potatoes separately until
almost tender
if we cooked them with the meat instead
we'd end up with a mushy texture in the
final dish
no thanks
once our potatoes are softened we're
going to fry them in a neutral oil to
provide texture to our dish and the
crunch doesn't stop there
next we're going to fry some onions a
must when it comes to bombay style
biryani we recommend using a small red
onion or shallot
we'll fry them until they're nice and
golden brown seriously look how good
those look
before we move on to layering our
biryani we're going to make some saffron
water
saffron adds a luxurious scent flavor
and color to our biryani
we know it can be pricey so if you don't
have saffron on hand use turmeric to get
that orange hue
we're going to pour hot water over our
saffron threads and then gently crush
them with the back of a spoon to get all
of that flavor out
now let's make our gravy we tested a few
different oils for our gravy and found
that a mixture of oil and ghee or
clarified butter creates the best flavor
without being too rich we'll heat our
oil mixture until it shimmers then we're
going to add all of our whole spices to
get every last drop of flavor out of
them
we want to fry them until they are
fragrant not burnt about one to two
minutes
then we'll add our chopped onions and
saute
once the onions begin to brown add the
tomatoes and cook for three to five
minutes
then add the marinated chicken a splash
of water and salt cover and let this
cook for 10 minutes
we'll add the potatoes back in and then
add our special ingredient prunes prunes
are used in bombay style biryani to add
an element of sweetness to the dish
now that our gravy is finished let's
move on to layering when it comes to
cooking biryani there are a few ways to
do it
you can cook it dum style which involves
layering raw ingredients in a heavy
bottomed pot and slow cooking them all
together
or you can make it pakka style which
means cooking all of the components
separately and then layering them
together after
we're cooking our biryani pakka style
because it's more traditional for bombay
style biryani and it ensures we don't
overcook any of the elements in the dish
we'll start by reserving half of the
beautiful gravy and add half of our rice
into the pot
then we'll sprinkle some of our saffron
water on top
we'll add some herbs a little ghee and
our fried onions as finishing touches
for the first layer and then we'll
repeat the whole process for the second
layer
once we have our biryani all piled up
we're going to cover the pot with foil
and seal it really tightly
traditionally we'd wrap the rim with
dough to get the tight seal we're
looking for but today we're going to
keep it simple by using foil
once it's done cooking we'll leave it
covered to rest for 10 minutes to let
the steam really fluff up the rice and
finish cooking
and there you have it your beautifully
layered bombay biryani
with biryani every bit of time taken to
perfect this dish really pays off we're
going to serve our biryani today with a
little onion raita and pickled mango we
know that nothing will beat your mom's
biryani but we think this recipe comes
very close
you